مع حلول اغسطس من العام 2022 كان على
الصينيين ان يعترفوا بانهم امام كارثه هي
الاكبر في تاريخ الاقتصاد فاعلنت الحكومه
تعرض البلاد لاكبر موجه جفاف منذ 157 عاما
انه الجفاف الضخم لنهر اليانسي ثالث اكبر
انهار العالم واطولها في اسيا فماذا حدث
في منطقه حوض نهر اليانكس الصينيه يحدث
الجفاف بشكل متكرر في الصيف حيث ترتفع
فيها درجات الحراره فوق 35 درجه مئويه
لمدد طويله قد تصل لنحو 20 يوما في
السنوات الاخيره شهدت المنطقه سلسله من
حالات الجفاف التاريخيه في المنطقه ابرزها
كان في اعوام
1785 و
1934 و 1978
في يوليو من العام 2022 شهد هطول الامطار
في حوض نهر اليانغتص انخفاضا بنسبه 45% عن
العام الماضي وهو ادنى مستوى له منذ عام
1961 ما تسبب في جفاف تام ببعض اجزاء
النهر تزامن ذلك مع موجات الحر الشديد
التي ضربت اجزاء كبيره من البلاد حيث سجلت
عشرات المدن درجات حراره مرتفعه تجاوزت
اربعين درجه سيلسيوس في بعض المناطق
استمر غياب الهطول المطري مصحوبا بموجات
الحراره العاليه لمده 70 يوما ليضع الجهات
الرسميه في اول حاله تاهب وطنيه للجفاف
منذ تسع سنوات
كان جنوب غرب الصين الاكثر تضررا في تشونج
تشنج وحدها جفا نحو 66 نهرا في 34 مقاطعه
تماما فيما انخفض منسوب نهر اليانتسي الى
النصف
تسببت قله هطول الامطار وموجات الحراره
المستمره في ازمه مياه حيث واجه نحو خمسه
ملايين شخص وتسعمائه الف راس من الماشيه
صعوبات في الحصول على مياه نظيفه فنقلت
مياه الشرب بالشاحنات الى المناطق التي
جفت فيها الامدادات السكنيه تماما
تعطل توليد الكهرباء في عدد من المحطات
الكهرومائيه الرئيسيه ما اثار ازمه وفوضى
في الكهرباء في اجزاء من البلاد ما دفع
هذه المدن الكبرى لاطفاء الانوار وتعطيل
السلالم المتحركه وخفض تشغيل المكيفات
وشهد السكان واطفاء انوار الواجهات
البحريه في شنغهاي وتعليق عرض الضوء
الشهير لنهر يانسي
وفي مقاطعه سيتشوان التي تعتمد بشكل كبير
على الطاقه الكهرومائيه اجبرت المصانع على
الاغلاق لمده سته ايام من اجل تقنين
امدادات الكهرباء فرض الجفاف اثارا خطيره
على الاقتصاد وسبل العيش وقطاع الزراعه
حيث بلغت مساحه الاراضي الزراعيه المتضرره
من الجفاف في حوض نهر اليانكسي نحو اربعه
ملايين هكتار واصدرت اربع وكالات حكوميه
بيانا تحذيريا بان حصاد الخريف تحت تهديد
خطير
احتاج اكثر من 780 الف شخص الى دعم حكومي
مباشر فيما قدرت وزاره الطوارئ الخسائر
الاقتصاديه المباشره من ارتفاع الحراره في
يوليو واحده بنحو 410 ملايين دولار ما دفع
الحكومه لاجراء تدابير عديده للحد من حجم
الخسائر
هو ليس زلزالا ولا فيضانا لكنه كارثه كبرى
هزت اقتصاد ثاني اكبر الدول اقتصاديا في
العالم فنهر اليانغتسي ليس مجرد سيل مائي
جاري فبالاضافه لكونه الممر الحيوي الاكثر
اهميه في البلاد فهو مصدر مياه الشرب
الاساسي لاكثر من 400 مليون صيني
[موسيقى]